in kinematics if we know acceleration
which we generally can get from Newton's
second law then we'd like to integrate
the acceleration to get velocity and
position how does that work for circular
motion well when you think about
circular motion and you think about the
tangential direction then that in some
sense is a one-dimensional motion and so
what we'll see is that the tangential
description of this motion can be
integrated to get the tangential
velocity and position just in a similar
way that we did with linear motion where
if we were giving the acceleration we
integrated velocity and positioned so
let's look at a particular example
suppose we're given that the tangential
component of the acceleration is given
by some simple polynomial a minus BT now
in this case the acceleration is
certainly non constant what we'd like to
do remember this is equal to our d
squared theta DT squared so if we
integrate the tangential component of
the acceleration with some variable from
T prime going from some initial value
which we can call zero to some final
value then that will give us the change
in the tangential velocity so for this
case the theta of T is equal to V theta
T naught plus the integral of a minus B
T prime DT Prime now we needed an
integration variable because recall that
our functional dependence is the upper
limit of the integral we saw that in
one-dimensional kinematics so we're
going from some T naught 0 to some prime
T prime well this integral is now we'll
write this be theta naught where again T
naught we're calling zero and when we do
this integral a minus B T prime DT Prime
that's an integral from 0 to
prime equals T T prime equals zero this
integral is not hard to do we get a of T
minus 1/2 B of T squared and there's
that constant initial term and so the
velocity at time T of the tangential
component of the velocity is given by
that expression in exactly the same
fashion the angle how much angle does
this go through well we have to be
careful there so if we want to do the
arc length s of T we have to multiply
the angle by the radius and that is just
the integral of the tangential component
of the velocity from T prime equals 0 to
time T prime T and so in this example we
have a slightly complicated integral V
not DT prime 0 to T I'm gonna drop I'll
write it in T prime plus the integrals a
T prime minus 1/2 B T prime squared I
didn't need to split this up but I'm
splitting it up anyway
and I have really one two three
integrals to do and what I get is V
theta naught T the result of the first
integral the result of the second
integral is one half a T squared and the
result of the third integral is minus
1/6 B T cubed and that gives me this I
have to be a little careful on this side
it's how much has the arc lengths
changed as we go from time 0 to time T
so that's the change in arc length
and that's a typical example of where
we're given tangential expel
acceleration we integrate it to get the
tangential velocity and then when we
integrate the tangential velocity we're
getting the change in arc length around
the circle